hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to well
there's no doubt about it
Nintendo games Rock movies based on that
Tendo games blah
therefore movies about Nintendo games
blow rocks
thus we enter the horrifying realms of
the wizard Nintendo's biggest
advertising fuckup sense Virtual Boy the
film about a little boy who seems to be
private G with Nintendo games literally
teaches the lesson that Nintendo games
bring families together and as we all
know that tender games make us wanna do
nothing but destroy our adversaries so
the idea of Nintendo being Canada's
8-bit Buddha was pretty damn stupid but
still they advertised this movie big
with stars like Fred Savage Christian
Slater a shitload of videogames
unintended tournament face off and even
a sneak peek at their latest
groundbreaking game which wasn't yet
released when you're a kid growing up in
the eighties in 90s this looked
unbelievable I mean every kid had to see
this so why is this film a letdown of
digital proportions let's take a look
first of all let's take a look at this
thrilling opening pretty exciting huh
[Music]
The Wizard champions of Nintendo duking
it out in a one-on-one tournament of the
Nintendo messed up my god is he still
walking seriously the opening of this
film is nothing but a kid walking down a
straight narrow road fasten your seat
belt okay so the strange little boy
walking down the road is a kid named
Jimmy who just wants to go to California
California California he's returned back
to his mother and Jack a stepfather
where he continues to stare blankly out
into space apparently he's been
traumatized by the death of his sister
and is seeking an outlet for all his
pent-up emotions I'd like to think that
he's searching for a way to express
himself if only there was some kind of
game Council with two-player game
playing 8-bit graphics that could allow
him to express himself but that kind of
all inspiring magic only exists in the
wildest realms of our imagination
meanwhile we cut the jimmies real father
played by Joe Bridges who surprisingly
was available we also get to see Jim
brothers Nick played by Christian Slater
and Corrine played by Fred Savage and I
never really noticed it before but Fred
Savage is kind of weird I mean he
doesn't really act like a kid at all
everything he says sounds like it's
being spoken by a high-pitched adult he
kind of sounds like a male version of
Dakota Fanning and I don't think that's
a good thing you know so he sits in his
room throwing darts at a mat because I
guess that's what kids did before the
Internet and decides he wants to take a
little vacation where no no
California California
the court decides he wants to run away
from home and live in California on his
way there he picks up his brother Jimmy
from a mental home where he literally
just walks in the front door and steals
him away there's a fuck security I mean
there's no sign the lock doors no
nothing did they just forget that
kidnapping is illegal what a top-notch
establishment I can't believe it once
news of their runaway hits the parents
the mother and stepfather hire a
professional runaway Bringer Becker
person named mr. Gutman but Cory's
father and brother are destined to get
them back first
because mr. Putman has the audacity to
bring them back while being mildly rude
I make my money by bringing kids in and
I don't make it if someone else brings a
kid in first we can't let him bring our
children back alive and well with such
hideously poor manners too Jim Avila
meanwhile Jimmy and Cory stop at a bus
station where they discovered that Jimmy
has a special talent for getting high
points on Double Dragon there they come
across Haley a girl who also happens to
be running away it's this problem just
shy shy a few bricks I'd say just kick
dance on Double Dragon get out of here
Kim yeah I could whack co2 no way
what abet how much got a bus ticket
Kasia death what kids talk like this I
mean seriously they all talk like
nineteen eighties businessmen I mean who
raised a Donald Trump fire Haley is
shocked to find out that Jimmy does beat
her at Double Dragon a boy defeats a
girl at a video game stop the presses
your attitude sucks
while boys dad and brother continued to
search women after stealing the tree
from Harold and Maude and decide to stay
in a hotel there Nick hooks up a
Nintendo system which seems to bring
this father and son closer together
doesn't take much intelligence to play
that game dinner you should know really
close together Fung go grab a bite to
eat
[Music]
really close together this will let you
know that
I'm glad that I'm here really
uncomfortably unnaturally unchristian ly
close together
Master she's taken rear it was great
sleeping with my father Nintendo it
makes you gay now you're playing with
incest can't even talk to each other
bring your underwear meanwhile Haley
tells Cory and Jimmy about a Nintendo
competition where they could win $50,000
and you'll never guess where it's being
held right you are you little oddball so
the three of them go from pit stop to
pit stop common people out of money by
making bets on video games which it
seems are mostly played by a lot of
middle-aged stuck-up white businessmen
you know easily absurd while gaining
more and more money one can recommend
Jimmy to the ultimate Nintendo Master
he's good but he never beat Lucas Lucas
oh don't tell me you've never heard of
Lucas he's only the greatest Nintendo
player that has ever roamed the universe
and now where might we find this Lucas
within the twilight of the full moon
when the sky is dark but the fire of the
stars pierces through the night that is
where you will find he's top he's cool
but most of all he's bad nobody's been
this you the wizard no yes is he like a
poster child for something hey Lucas man
that was great they say that he's better
God look more than them
Lucas is awesome begin he gave me one I
have 97 Dirty Harry star Bates
The Terminator Lawrence just make
yourself useful give me a cold drink but
not only is Lucas a Nintendo master he
is also the keeper of a greater magic
[Music]
what could be so important he has to
keep in that briefcase
[Music]
the legends were true
power bluff it's even more beautiful
than I imagined
[Music]
move down Lucas look out my god he's a
bad man good looking bad bad
it's like watching Michelangelo
carbon-steel of David but with a cop
[Music]
I love the power glove
it's so big oh yeah we'll just keep your
power gloves off her pal huh
what oh I'm sorry
I forgot to make room for your
spontaneous romance that literally
started right now all this sexual
tension gets to Jimmy as he runs out of
the room well Lucas tells Haley that
he'll be entering the Nintendo
competition too but surely they don't
have any openings for God's is that
right
meanwhile we take a look at the
continuing escapades family and
professional child catcher mister how
dare you try to bring our children back
to us safe and sound
then they partake in some really stupid
car scenes that remind you a lot of an
old Dukes of Hazzard episode now then
Duke boys I better plug in the game
genie or look up some cheat codes cuz
there ain't no way that getting outta
this one with all their lives
[Music]
Nintendo it makes you want to crash into
people now you're playing with vehicular
manslaughter so to get ready for the
tournament
Jimmy has to study as many Nintendo
games as quickly as possible while
playing they also enlist the help of a
Nintendo Power hot liners god bless you
Nintendo helping kids cheat the right
way while that's going on mister Putman
finally locates the kids outside the
swimming pool wait a minute what the
hell I'm sorry I'm sorry I can't focus
with an old man but she's hanging out in
the background I mean what were they
thinking did somebody actually look at
this scene and say you know what's
missing here an old man's package that
literally adds much needed drama
disgusting and if you think this movie
can't possibly get any more
uncomfortable just listen to this
to Nintendo it makes you want to touch
children now you're playing with
pedophilia and that's just wrong
Cory's dad and brother aren't far behind
when they come across a guy when Jimmy's
hand where'd you get that hat a couple
kids tell me some cash
hey I'll tell you whether we're going
where Lucas darling so the three kids
make it to the competition that's held
at the other shameful plug in this movie
Universal Studios when they come across
some very strange adults playing ninja
guy hi I'm up here my little beauties
you get the station you know I think I
finally figured out the main problem
with this movie all the 12 year olds act
like 30 year old and all the 30 year old
act like 12 year olds it's like a
topsy-turvy world but only Hollywood's
limited understanding of reality could
give us while there they come across an
old enemy perfection you know I hope you
don't get nervous like last time those
we wouldn't want you to quiz on someone
oh mercy Lucas mercy but there's Jimmy
enters the tournament we find that he
actually does pretty good and mix it to
the final three
where they get to play a brand-new game
nobody said this movie would suck either
life's a bitch deal with it later we
find that mr. Putman has made it to the
tournament - he almost doesn't spot them
until somebody gives away no location
[Music]
Lucas as we follow them through a chase
slash promotional tour of Universal
Studios Putman finally traps them in the
back of a storage room just above the
tournament but the kids have an
ingenious way to escape an elevator what
will they think of next
oh what's miscarriages automaton mobiles
I hate you so Jimmy makes it to the
final round where we find the mother of
all brand-new games is finally revealed
[Music]
fucking shit Super Mario Brothers hurry
double directly added in south-central
up whether you're a leaf out
laughs so the game is quite literally on
as Jimmy and Lucas go thumb to thumb in
an epic battle for Nintendo
no Jimmy no
[Applause]
remember your training
Oh
[Music]
don't worry well kiss you'll get out
next time so after he wins the
tournament everybody finally starts to
head home but Jimmy finds the dinosaurs
that were in pee-wee's big adventure and
has to go in so why did you me want to
go to California all this time to all of
us I guess just wonderful leave our
place where she was happy
Wow how phenomenally unsatisfying I mean
how much more anti-climactic can you
possibly get if you're gonna have
dinosaurs in a movie about Nintendo
games Theodore fucking eat somebody
we're doing it good bottom line it's
always more fun to actually play video
games that is to watch people play video
games and this movie is living proof of
it and top of that I think everybody's
career actually got destroyed because of
this movie I mean look at the director
what did he move on to just directing
the majority of all the malcolm in the
middle of those zones
okay that example how about Fred Savage
can you think of anything that he moved
on to do okay okay but I'm sure that
Christian Slater kid never moved on into
any kind of famous publicity okay all
right Jimmy the little child prodigy in
the movie surely spending your entire
life just playing video games can't get
you any kind of fame
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god